bonjour à tous alors tout d'abord je
voudrais remercier donc le tedx abidjian
de m'avoir invité aujourd'hui si je suis
là aujourd'hui devant vous c'est que
quelque part j'ai dû réussir quelque
chose
donc pour commencer je vais me présenter
donc je suis isabelle moreno j'ai 41 ans
je vais vous raconter un peu la première
partie de ma vie et ensuite la deuxième
partie de ma vie donc la première partie
de ma vie
s'il vous plaît ne m'a pas donné la
télécommande merci alors la première
partie de ma vie est une vie codé
pourquoi codé parce que je suis issu
d'une famille de quatre filles dont
quatre filles avec papa maman
nous vivons à 10mo cros à oumé ada loi
puis à abidjan je suis né à abidjan le
18 juin
ah pardon final la loi le 18 juin 1975
donc alors mes quatre soeurs mes trois
soeurs et moi sommes à la maison avec
nos parents et nous suivons bien sûr les
codes
nous allons à l'école nous avons notre
éducation on nous apprend les valeurs et
les valeurs c'est ce qu'on a c'est la
chose la plus importante qu'on entend
dans la vie ce sont les bases que nos
parents ou alors tout ce qu'on a à
l'extérieur peut nous apporter
et c'est ce qu'on va utiliser après pour
plus tard alors je fais des études bien
sûr je suis brillante à l'école jusqu'en
cm2 donc je suis
on a fait de la loi ou mais demo cros et
je me retrouve donc à 10 ans à abidjan
abidjan
je passe d'une école publique qui était
le ppt moins de deux dalles de dimbokro
où on jouait à temps passe à l'aréa
kallag récréation par exemple à une
école française ou à la récréation va
jouer au gendarme et au voleur d'accord
très bien donc déjà ça m'a appris à
pouvoir m'adapter à toutes les
situations et à tous les milieux donc je
peux tout autant mangé à la main n'a
tiqué poisson ou alors inquiète
ou alors me servir vraiment de mai
couvert et ça c'est tout l'éducation que
j'ai reçue de mes parents de la vie et
ensuite donc à la fin de mes études j'ai
donc comme je vous ai dit c'est le
cursus normal et à la fin donc j'ai été
dans la vie professionnelle
normal donc j'ai eu trois emplois
mon premier emploi était comme
commercial dans une société qui faisait
de la distribution de coton donc j'étais
juste commercial fallu démarcher dans
notre coton dans les pharmacies traiter
avec donc les grossistes etc
deuxième métier le négoce du café cacao
où j'étais au service administration
donc j'étais chargé de faire tout ce qui
était remise documentaire pour
l'expédition de nos produits en europe
aux états unis et c'est donc
l'exportation du café cacao
ensuite en 2002 j'ai eu donc mon enfant
donc monfils en est né en 2002 et pour
moi ça a été vraiment le moment crucial
de ma vie mon fils qui naît en 2002 et
il fallait après les congés de maternité
devoir repartir au travail c'était
vraiment pesant et je me disais mais
pourquoi isabelle qu'il n'essaierait pas
autre chose tu n'essaierait pas vraiment
de faire quelque chose qui te plaît mais
j'ai gardé ça dans un coin de ma tête
mais j'ai quand même repris le travail
entre temps où savez quand on commence à
travailler on a envie de gagner de
l'argent on a envie vraiment de ce2 ce2
se faire reconnaître dans ce qu'on fait
de savoir que oui vous avez un beau un
bon salaire à la fin du mois est tous
très bien
entre temps donc il ya un de mes amis
qui me débauche et qui me propose
beaucoup d'argent je suis très bien payé
et je fais de l'événementiel je les fais
pendant un an et demi
mais pendant un an et demi c'était
d'accord je m'épanouis au travail on a
beaucoup de travail on a on réussit des
spectacles ont réussi vraiment des
divertissements etc
je me dis mais je n'ai pas assez de
temps pour mon fils et j'ai pas
l'impression de faire quelque chose que
j'aime vraiment donc qu'est-ce que je
peux faire et c'est là où j'ai eu j'ai
eu l'idée en fait et comme quoi j'étais
quand même
il y avait quand même une vocation en
moi que je ne savais pas parce que
pendant mes études en fait j'avais fait
un mémoire sur le maquillage mais
j'avais vraiment pas l'intention de
faire du maquillage à ces moments
vraiment pas alors ce que je fais c'est
qu'en 2004 je décide de démissionner et
de m'essayer à ma passion mon fils à
deux ans comme ça je fais ma passion qui
est le maquillage et à côté de ça ça me
permet quand même de gagner ma vie avec
ce que j'ai choisi
donc c'est juste un ballon d'essai ou
alors me dire je fais ça un certain
temps et après je passe à autre chose je
reviens dans la vie active ya pas de
problème j'aurais un travail toute façon
je trouverais d'accord donc la passion
pour moi c'est quoi commencer a commencé
je me dis j'aime le maquillage des
femmes aimant en maquillage comment je
peux développer ça très bien 2004 ne
savait qu'on a eu les zélés les
événements de septembre 2004 donc mon
fils et moi nous sommes rapatriées en
france et je me dis mais c'est
l'occasion pour moi d'essayer vraiment
ce que j'ai dit pourquoi pas
donc je vais je fais de la prospection
enfin je regarde un peu à paris donc les
magasins professionnels de maquillage
pour voir comment pouvoir faire une
mallette professionnels pour revenir à
abidjan pour pouvoir donc maintenant
occupé des femmes à abidjan je me
rappelle très bien d'une phrase qu une
amie m'a dit elle m'a dit elle m'a
demandé mes isabelle pourquoi tu fais ça
parce que tout le monde pensait que
j'étais devenu mais une extraterrestre
les folles comment elle peut abandonner
un travail où à l'époque a gagné 900
mille net pour venir vous vendre du
maquillage elle en plus ça ça demande
beaucoup d'humilité parce que c'est dû
faire du porte à porte ou alors demandé
à plaider à miller
/ ame et voilà je vends de maquillage
aimerait bien de proposer ce que j'ai
dans ma mallette je vais te montrer
comment on fait si je suis venu avec la
mallette que je vais vous montrer
il s'assied de fletch même passé la
mallette qui en bas merci merci beaucoup
alors cette mallette je vous la présente
en 2004 c'est avec celle là que j'ai
commencé
comment j'ai rempli ma mallette quand
j'ai vu les fournisseurs dans mon fils
était dans sa poussette
on y rentrer dans le magasin donc le
monsieur qui nous regardent bonjour
madame pour jour les murs le petit 1
merci hockey et j'ai dit bon voilà je
vis en côte d'ivoire et je voudrais en
fait acheté du maquillage avec vous
qu'est ce qu'elles sont vos conditions
vous savez j'ai pas beaucoup d'argent
mais je veux vraiment essayé ça me dit
ok ok bon d'accord on va essayer si vous
me prenez trois produits de charges ou
fait 50%
ok très bien d'accord bon je vais je
choisis mes produits je les mets dans ma
trousse mis en confiance nettement mais
il fallait investir aussi dans tout ce
qui est hester
donc c'est pas grave je mets les
testeurs en eau tout ce qui a à vendre
en bas et après qu'est ce que je fais je
rentre à abidjan abidjan le nouveau
travail tabasser quoi elle et
maquilleuse 9 il disait alors je prends
mon téléphone et donc j'appelle d'abord
ma famille mes amis ma première cliente
masseur josiane donc ma fait ma première
trousses c'était gentil donc la famille
venait acheter un peu de bouche à
oreille donc les gens commençaient à
m'approcher oui isabelle en après
quotité maquilleuse m'a qui est bien est
ce que vous aimez venir me maquiller on
vit en moi j'appelle oui est ce que je
peux vous présenter les produits que
j'ai ce que je peut vous venir vous voir
et c'est donc c'est vraiment la trousse
dans le coffre
on a un riche et la cliente on descend
la trousse elle nous installe soit dans
sa salle de bain soit alors au salon est
fait sortir ses produits de maquillage
qu'elle a je lui montre ce que j'ai en
échange à la fin le deal c'est quoi non
seulement elle me prend des produits
mais je la fis délice parce que bien sûr
tout ce que j'ai appris avant à l'école
même servir donc je fais des fiches
ante et je commence donc à suivre mes
clientes à leur vendent souvent du
maquillage par exemple cérémonie m
appelle excité donc ça c'est la première
partie la mallette ensuite qu'est ce que
je fais je me dis mes meilleures
clientes ne sont pas celles que je
connais il avait passe à autre chose
donc je décide en fait de chercher un
magasin que je peux transformer en fait
en institut de beauté institut de beauté
isabelle maquilleuse déjà c'est juste
une passion parce que tu m'as qui y est
écrit et étaient copines donc comment tu
vas faire avec l'esthétique
tu n'es pas esthéticienne qu'est ce que
je fais je prends une esthéticienne qui
sera donc ma béquille qui va m'aider à
pouvoir avoir le premier institut moreno
en 2007 j'ai sauté une étape avant de
passer à excuser moi avant de passer
donc à la comaga à l'institut de beauté
en fait j'ai créé un petit show room à
la maison donc il y avait une pièce
dédiée au maquillage à la maison qui
était dans la cour mais ce qui était
vraiment aménagé comme un magasin mais
où ne faisait uniquement que du
maquillage c'était un labo de maquillage
donc ventes de maquillage prestation
maquillage ou alors on m'appelait à
l'extérieur pour but maquiller pour des
publicités par exemple après cette étape
donc en 2007 je décide de d'ouvrir donc
le premier institut avec l'esthéticienne
donc on commence donc ca de niveau
maquillage au rez-de-chaussée et au
premier étage dont quand même au niveau
de la mezzanine tout ce qui est soit son
esthétique soins du visage soins du
corps tout ce qui semblerait ça commence
à prendre
isabelle commence à voir de la notoriété
d'accord il fera trop il faut trouver un
nom avant ça avant c'était juste moreno
isabelle coach beauté et bien-être
ok donc il faut chercher un nom cherche
on fait des réunions oui vous voyez des
mois trouver un nom etc
sparkle beauty success maquillage côte
d'ivoire
tout ça ça ne vient pas je dis bon je
vais faire simple je vais utiliser mon
nom et en plus mon père étant décédé en
2006 en décembre 2006
en 2007 quand j'ai ouvert je me suis dit
ah mais tiens on a un joli nom moreno
s'assemblent ça sonne bien
si je rajoutais justin apostrophé un ace
je trouve que ça fait très jolie en plus
ça fait ça à partir moreno sujet seysses
et ceux non je ne regretterai jamais de
l'avoir donné et c'est comme si c'était
mon père même qui m'aidaient au
quotidien à faire donc l'épanouissement
de cette entreprise donc c'est ce que
j'ai appelé de l'idéal entreprises donc
on est passé par les étapes on quitte la
vie professionnelle normale on se lance
dans un projet qui a priori n'est pas un
projet qui est intéressant pour une
femme qui a quand même un background qui
a quand même fait des études c'est un
secteur en général quand tu es coiffeuse
esthéticienne ou couturière c'est un
domaine qui risque qui est réservé en
fait aux personnes qui n'ont pas réussi
à l'école à l'époque où j'ai commencé
moreno il n'y avait pas beaucoup de
maquilleuses le métier de meta partie ce
n'était vraiment pas là modem et à
abidjan ça c'est numéro un numéro 2 à
l'époque où j'ai commencé mon rheinau zh
il y avait des instituts de beauté
d'accord mais qui ne faisait pas
vraiment d'efforts en termes de
diversité ou bien en termes pour vous
dire même même pour maquiller
à l'époque les filles maquillées encore
avec les doigts qui n'était pas de
pinceau et vont en faire des crayons des
traits de crayon à d'eyeliner je veux
dire tout ça a changé au fur et à mesure
et je pense que j'ai aidé ce secteur est
un secteur qui est devenu un secteur
porteur où je pense que je serai même la
cause pour certains d'entre vous vos
enfants vous diront ah j'ai envie
d'ouvrir un institut de beauté très bien
alors ce que je ce qu'on a fait après
donc le dida l'entreprise j'ai créé donc
comme je vous ai dit le premier institut
moreno ensuite je me suis dit on est en
zone 4 ça serait bien qu'on aille de
l'autre côté du pont aussi parce que si
là-bas où il ya les zones résidentielles
eu beaucoup plus de monde donc je
cherche un local et je trouve encore une
fois dieu merci
une
un local donc qui est pratiquement en
bord dick est carrément en bordure de
route aux deux plateaux zone de grand
passage une villa mais délabré de chez
délabré je me dis c'est pas grave moi je
suis forte je vais y aller on a fait les
travaux j'ai pris on a fait des travaux
on a ouvert l'institut de plateau moreno
ça marchait je suis contente on a
plusieurs esthéticienne même a marre
comme amazon cas donc on a deux
esthéticiennes plus isabelle aux deux
plateaux on a 5 à 6 yens et isabelle
fait le va et vient
ça marche très bien on est content
isabelle tue pas s'arrêter à ça non
pourquoi donc ce que je fais je décide
d'ouvrir un troisième institut de beauté
où je réfléchis la clientèle est quand
même plus ivoirienne africaine et puis
aux zones 4g quelques européenne mais
les libanais je les ai pas il faut que
je les ai aussi les i pas les libanaises
et son où elles sont à la rue de la paix
rue de la paix
marcory je cherche un local je trouve le
local très bien petit local
je le prends je vis il est bien placé
toute façon je veux pas en faire quelque
chose de très gros donc je décide de le
prendre
troisième institut alors là c'est là où
je suis revenue sur terre parce que je
n'avais plus de vie moi qui avait changé
qui avait décidé de changer de vie pour
m'occuper plus de mon enfant pour
pouvoir être plus à la maison avec mon
époux pour pouvoir gérer mon temps en
fait je me suis retrouvé à avoir une vie
où il fallait faire le tour parce que
c'est ce sont des services qu'on fait si
vous n'êtes pas là les filles ne vont
pas forcément faire le travail comme
vous voulez calcul se fassent elles ne
sont pas forcément ordonné donc la
répétition ehpad et pédagogique donc
vous faire des visites surprises pour
que tout soit bien impeccable
donc c'était vraiment très difficile
d'avoir à faire trois sites
je me dis à isabelle c'est vrai que tu
as des clientes à marcory mais pense à
autre chose donc j'ai mis ça d'un coup
d'un côté de ma tête et j'ai continué
comme ça mais il ya certains centres que
je délaissait je ne pouvais pas être
partout à la fois
donc ce que je fais c'est que je décide
donc de d'avoir une idée j'ai dit bon
puisque je dois avoir des produits qu'on
ne fabrique pas ici il faut de la cire
dans un institut de beauté
il faut des spatules il faut tout le
consommables nécessaires aux
esthéticiennes vous passez slip jetables
et charlotte et hydra et je suis à
chaque fois obligé de prendre l'avion
allait chercher les affaires revenir
isabelle prend en gros ce qui ce qui
fera que tu seras toi même en système
intégré ce qui fera que toi même tu
pourrais être ta propre cliente même si
les autres ne viennent pas chez toi dans
un premier temps mais de toute manière
les autres doivent venir chez toi s'il
ya des bons prix pourquoi parce que tout
le monde n'a pas de visa je ne vise pas
forcément les dames pour la possibilité
de voyager mais tout le système informel
même qui existe a besoin de c2c de ces
matériaux là pour pouvoir travailler
donc je décide de faire le magasin
moreno shop à la place de l'institut
moreno ce homard à marcory et alors ce
qui se passe c'est que vu que j'ai
maintenant deux instituts de beauté dont
je dois m'occuper donc là c'est gérable
parce que c'est juste donne 4 2 plateaux
donc on fait un match et moitié aller à
des rendez-vous les églises qui
travaille très bien on peut pouvoir
surveiller tout ça donc je décide donc
de de consolider tout ça mais je
m'ennuie un peu
donc qu'est ce que je fais qu'est ce
qu'ils avaient fait faire encore à
l'époque je défilais donc je vais
utiliser quand même quelque chose
quelque chose encore supplémentaire que
je sais faire
donc organisé des défilés de mode
traiter des basses tâches
qu'est ce que tu peux faire 2013 donc je
décide de faire mourinho ce fashion qui
aujourd'hui à satiété de septième
édition
donc on le fait deux fois par an ce qui
permet de faire de la publicité
détournée parce que tout le monde sait
que la publicité c'est quand même cher
si on n'a pas de l'argent on peut pas le
faire donc ça me permet de récompenser
mes clientes
mes clients est de pouvoir avoir des
annonceurs qui m'accompagne qui me
permettent ainsi de faire un événement
qui plaît au public
donc tout le monde est content tu es
content finish parce que ce qui est
important c'est d'être d'être d'avoir
dépassé dès des activités
'gagnant-gagnant' donc aujourd'hui
moreno est un et 1 est une entité qu'est
parti en fait du maquillage ni aux
courriers aujourd'hui regroupe deux
instituts de beauté un moreno choc donc
et de la distribution de produits
esthétiques pour tout les esthéticiennes
ensuite le l'événement deux fois par an
et pour finir tout ça donc il ya cela
nous permet en fait de pouvoir viser
encore d'autres choses
donc dans le futur j'aimerais pouvoir
faire des franchises et vraiment c'est
toutes les valeurs que mes parents m'ont
inculqué
c'est tout le travail que j'ai dû faire
c'est tout ce que j'ai pu regrouper pour
pouvoir donc construire tout ça qui me
permettent d'être là aujourd'hui devant
vous et vraiment je suis vraiment très
très reconnaissante nommé envers mes
parents donc ce que je dis c'est qu'il
faut se connaître avant tout ce en quoi
je crois en tout cas mais credo c'est
que 1
il faut se connaître donc savoir ce
qu'on veut vraiment faire dans la vie
vraiment va savoir ce qu'on sait faire
dans la vie le faire bien tout en
respectant les autres parce que la
première chose c'est de respecter
l'amour du prochain c'est d'être
courageux dans son travail c'est d'être
toujours bienveillant et surtout très
travailleur une fois qu'on fait tout ça
on peut normalement réussir ce qu'on a
entrepris si on le fait vraiment avec
passion et ça j'y crois fortement
ensuite il faut se donner les moyens se
donner les moyens c'est vraiment cherché
par tous les moyens possibles et
imaginables à se perfectionner et à
savoir faire les choses correctement
on ne fait pas les chics ans se décide
de faire quelque chose il faut le faire
bien
il faut se donner les moyens de bien le
faire et en premier il faut toujours
compter sur soi même parce que quand on
décide d'être entrepreneur tout repose
sur soi mais il faut s'entourer de
personnes compétentes qui peuvent vous
aider à consolider tout ça et pouvoir
toujours aller plus haut donc j'en
courage tout le monde ici qui a un
projet qui a une idée qui a une passion
à pouvoir la développer à pouvoir
vraiment la consolider pour pouvoir
arriver loin plus tard voilà je vous
remercie